je ne sais pas
[Musique]
zoubir donc été qu'un rejoint les
princes et les princesses de l'amour
alors pourquoi vous avez rejoint les
princes et les princesses de labour déjà
peut-être dans la police on rappelle moi
débat ça faisait un petit moment qu'on
me disais voilà le profil télé etc
c'est un petit moment j'avais envie de
voir ailleurs pour changer un petit peu
de domaines
ouais faire plaisir on me dit devant un
tel profil etc je me suis dit ça va être
l'occasion
voilà de m'épanouir devoir à quelque
chose de nouveau et si on imprime je
peux repartir avec une belle princesse
bnf alors c'est à la suite de cette
apparition que les soucis aurait
commencé votre hiérarchie vous reproche
notamment de ne pas les avoir prévenus
est ce que vous aviez prévenu votre
hiérarchie que vous allez faire
les princes et les princesses de labour
non je ne sais pas prévenu alors que ça
fait un petit moment que déjà je suis en
rupture géant fracture avec avec
l'institution en général avec ma
hiérarchie ne les a pas prévenus
mais n'avait pas pris de l'allant selon
vous candidat et télé réalité et
policiers c'est compatible
mon avis est que ça peut être compatible
à partir du moment où quand je vais dans
ce genre de programme je décline pas ma
qualité de policier mais à aucun moment
j'ai décliné ma qualité de policier à
partir du moment où je fais pas quelque
chose de entre guillemets indigne j'ai
un comportement assez noble on cherche
l'amour voilà pour moi pour moi ce n'est
pas censé apporter les porter préjudice
je vous explique en gros mois j'ai pris
un congé il ya un an en début d'année en
début 2001 j'ai pris un congé sans solde
une dispo c'est à dire qu'à partir de ce
moment de jeu dépend plus de la police
je suis un peu ce que je veux et c'est
entre guillemets je suis gérant plus de
la police
je ne suis plus rémunérés quand j'ai
fait ça tu disposes c'était justement
pour me lancer dans le projet de
mannequinat et c'est ça n'a pas marché
il est le co vide donc moi fallait que
je remplisse le frigo j'ai des charges
et des loyers
je me suis retrouvé à rungis à bosser à
3 heures du matin dans le froid donc à
partir du moment où à partir de ce
moment là je suis rentré je suis revenu
dans la police entre temps avant j'ai
passé des castings de télé j'ai passé
les castings 1 2 3 j avais oublié je
suis rentré dans la police
j'ai repris et à ce moment là j'ai eu
des retours faut savoir qu'avant de
reprendre j'ai repris je suis resté coi
une semaine et je me suis mis en arrêt
après parce que ça faisait un moment
déjà que j'avais un petit souci là bas
que les tous les délires de deux
contrôles au faciès de racisme de il y
avait beaucoup de comportements qui me
gênait dans la police est donc large
arrivait plus à me reconnaître en fait
donc lalalalala vous là vous dites que
voilà vous aviez la police ça vous
correspondez pas pour vous vous avez
vraiment vu des comportements comme ça
tu devrais en fait juste après c'est moi
j'étais en arrêt et quand juste pour
préciser au moment où je suis parti sur
l'épreuve était déjà en arrêt j'étais en
déni complètement avec l'institution
j'étais chez moi je travaillais plus à
ce moment-là mois il
des comportements qui m'ont gêné qui ont
fait que ça fait un moment et encore une
fois je crache pas sur l'institution je
parle de certains comportements que j'ai
vue opérées auprès des personnes qui
représente l'institution
mais quand une femme ayant déposé
plainte à 18h55 et que le plantier qui
finit à 19 heures il dit il va vient de
déposer plainte pour viol et le petit à
petit le platier il dit elle n'aurait
pas pu déposer plainte pour viol alors
pas pu se faire violer un autre jour ça
c'est des comportements que je cautionne
pas faire des concours d'amande sur le
groupe what that de la brigade c'est à
dire c'est quoi ça les concours d'amande
pendant gros ouais moi j'ai mis santé a
enfin terrasser les amendes moi j'ai me
sentais à aujourd'hui moi j'en ai mis
deux sens je suis pas rentré pour ça je
suis pas rentré pour sa fin cette fois
comme beaucoup d'adrénaline et oui moi
quand je suis rentré je suis rentré en
2017 dans la police quand je suis rentré
en plus je viens d'un endroit où ça aime
pas trop la police voilà donc moi
j'avais mal d'à priori du tout devient
de sartrouville
moi je suis rentré sans avis je viens
d'un endroit qui n'est pas la police je
rentre d'un policier mais aimerait finir
que tu aimes
non non mais positionnement qui est
quand même un peu je pense faudrait
laisser finir bon on va les aider
justement j'ai pas eu d' à priori parce
que je suis rentré en me disant je faire
des choses bien je vais changer les
choses je suis jeune je suis dynamique
je vais rentrer pour de bonnes causes
pour faire quelque chose de bon je suis
rentré puis au bout d'un moment je me
suis heurté à pas mal de trucs pas mal
de comportement le manque de
reconnaissance
certains comportements web xénophobes en
fait clairement il ya pas mal de
comportement c'est très fermé d'esprit
qui m'ont gêné c'est pas l'institut la
police estime de racisme et voilà j'ai
été victime de racisme s'est pas
directement en fait ces gens alors on va
descendre on va contrôler tes semblables
ou bien les chefs de brigade qui mettent
des trucs xénophobes sur facebook enfin
et ça ça posera de problème sur quoi sur
l'islam simplement sur l'islam on vient
surtout que ça te gêne pas de faire des
ajustements
mais justement voir les vidéos des
petites toques de zoubir c'est ça qu'est
aussi déranger vos collègues et
supérieurs de la police ont alors après
aussi votre avis bien entendu ça c'est
rien ça c'est ma mère qui hausse
laval je suis dans le gac att voilà
alors alors ça bruno pomart on vous
allez donnez votre avis dans un instant
et ça ça avec lui ni temps mais tout ça
passe pas du tout c'est désolant c'est
pathétique désolant faire il a d'autres
qualités c'est dommage qui les
exploitent en faisant ça et en
démystifiant et un donner une image une
image lamentable de l'uniforme
l'uniforme ne mérite pas ça il faudrait
pas voir ça ouais ça me fait du mal
parce que il est il est issu de la
diversité ce jeune homme
et c'est bien qu'on ait des gens comme
lui d'un autre policier il y en a
beaucoup
faut savoir que c'est l'administration
où il ya le plus de diversité donc
lorsqu'il dit que la police ait et
xénophobes racistes etc
ça c'est encore des clichés évidemment
parce qu on a trois cent mille policiers
lorsqu'il dit ça il jette l'opprobre sur
trois cent mille policiers et gendarmes
et qui travaille tous les jours à la
sécurité des citoyens donc l'entente de
dire ça il faut mieux que ça n'aille je
pense qu'il va s'en aller effectivement
je pense que même qui va être révoqués
de l'administration c'est moi la passion
d'être révoqué de la police
mais oui parce que si vous voulez c'est
dommage il est plein de qualités ce
garçon c'est dommage parce que la police
a besoin de renouveau utiliser les
réseaux sociaux c'est quelque chose
d'intéressant et d'ailleurs darmanin a
abondé dans ce sens puisqu'il a lancé un
snapshot
donc ça veut dire que la policière la
police a envie d'évoluer sur ces sujets
de la communication mais c'est dommage
que tu te ridiculise et que tu
ridiculise la maison police en faisant
ce que tu fais la transmission en temps
des souvenirs que vous ridiculiser la
maison police par bruno pomart et par
vaux par vos supérieurs il ya un
signalement qui aurait été fait sur la
plateforme de l'igpn l'inspection
générale de la police nationale
parce que vous savez qui est à l'origine
de signalement des gens qu'ils avaient
été dénoncés par un collègue très saint
connec moi je sais qui en fait moi
pendant ça fait plusieurs semaines
il ya des groupes de deux collègues
enfin qu'ils sont en train de se faire
une ligne fondé groupe et tout autre
ailleurs web contre moi ils savaient dès
story ça ressort enfin pas mal d'infos
personnelles sur moi sur ma famille le
compte instagram ma petite soeur qui a
13 ans ça va super lent et je vois pas
comme enfin ils sont super soudée pour
faire tomber je comprends pas
jusqu'aujourd'hui mais quand je pense
qu'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui franchement
en france la police
c'est un jeune de 25 ans qui fait des
tic toc et franchement c'est votre avis
donc par votre position et votre passé
je comprends que vous défendez 15e
l'institution n'y a pas de problème mais
encore une fois je veux juste aider
travers le monde et si jean herment et
deuxièmement moi de ce que je vois sur
les réseaux des commentaires des gens
qui me suivent
je reçois énormément de messages tu
donne une bonne image de la police ça se
voit que notre approche de la population
etc
il n'y a pas de haine dans ce que je
fais n'y a rien de mal y'a rien de
méchant dans ce que je fais et
franchement si on peut dire c'est que je
voudrais pas des bavures et que ça
fracasse quelqu'un ça fait des cagnottes
litchi mais moi qui fais des vidéos qui
essaie de véhiculer un message de paix
là par contre acharnement à recycler un
mois le sentiment que j'ai c'est vous
n'étiez pas heureux dans la police oui
c'est possible et que ne sais pas ce que
vous vouliez faire en fait j'ai
l'impression
vous vous êtes trompé de casting c'est à
dire vous êtes arrivé dans la prière
vous aviez un truc dans la tête vous
attardez des reprises et des annonces
est pas tout à fait comme ça qui est
dommage
cyril c'est que ce garçon il a plein de
talent dans ce qu'il fait sur tille
hadorn
mais les utilise pas n'utilise pas le
produit policiers c'est terrible quand
c'est terrible pour notre image je
t'assure tu as tu as de l'impac auprès
des jeunes et à mieux mais et de
l'impact positif et ne casse pas une
profession comme la nôtre qui est déjà
hyper compliqué dans la société actuelle
tu le sais voilà les policiers ne
méritait pas ça il ya 300 milles mais
qui travaille pour la sécurité de ce
pays pour la sécurité des citoyens
tu peux pas faire ça c'est pas vrai tu
as tu as d'autres talents exploiter les
ailleurs moi je veux quelque chose je
sais c'est pas subjectivité dans tous
les cas c'est un avis qui va être
subjectif mais moi je sais que auprès de
certaines personnes je donne pas une
mauvaise image
j'en suis convaincu